hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a man who has looked at the
world around him come to the conclusion
that it is not fair and not just and
decided to try and do something about it
and here is that man tita over at very
very much for joining us here in Berlin
today with talk yes it's a pleasure
great stuff now dieter over art is one
of the key figures in the fair trade
movement here in Germany he's currently
the managing director of the
increasingly influential organization
called transfer which he established
just over two decades ago the declared
aim is quite simply to get more fair
trade products into consumers shopping
carts and that could I tell you include
flowers because we've never had flowers
here on the talking Germany show before
but we do have today because DITA has
brought some along for us as an example
of fair trade ya even in a supermarket
around the corner so as a taxi driver I
had to drive five minutes more this is
after you get arrived in Berlin from the
airport yeah and and we just used an
ordinary supermarket here and that is
let's say one principle that you have
not to go any longer only to a third
world shop yeah I'm said you can do your
fare dropping just around the corner and
around the corner at a local supermarket
here in Berlin you brought the flowers
which have your seal your fair trade
yeah you are a man who is V associated
with fair trade in Germany here and with
the with the seal here tell me what fair
trade is I mean it's a it's a term that
everybody has heard i think but i'm not
sure that everybody understands it yeah
they are clear criterias so we are
setting standards in each product
category for example here in flowers we
define a prima fetid premium of ten
percent of the fo be price and this
thing what price was a free on board ok
that means ten percent has to go to a
special account and only the workers of
the flower farm in this case it's a flam
a farm in Ethiopia and easy they can
decide what we should do
with fair trade premium if it goes into
better education if it goes into health
programs in housing etc it doesn't go to
the management so our aim is not that
the farm owner gets richer our aim is to
empower producers and in other products
like in coffee we define a minimum price
and the production costs at least it has
to production costs and then also a fair
trade premium which goes above and send
the small farmers in Latin America in
Africa in india etc can decide by
themself what to do and this is under
control ok we'll talk much much more
about that in detail now I've understood
the first principles of fair trade yeah
we're going to find out more about fair
trade i'd like to just get a word from
you first of all though in my
introduction to you i said you're the
kind of person who looks at the world
and decided that it's not fair it's not
just he wants to change the world is
that true is that who you are here I
sing on one hand the cert world is
putting all the products on the table
the closing is mostly produced in Asia
are and and then some whales and we want
everything Jeep and I think that's
unfair because if when we sell a German
folk swag and somewhere on the world or
any kind of machine we wander a certain
price and we say the workers have to get
a good salary etc etc when we get
products from somewhere else in the
world we think it has to be as cheap as
possible and this is unfair and even in
our own interest I think we should be
interested that living conditions are
getting better in Africa or in other
areas and due to our understandings it
has to be done by trade and not aid I
think we have to overcome this attitude
ok you've had the first impressions
there from data over out here is a
little bit more especially about the
organization that he runs
it all began with coffee pic is on this
plantation and Guatemala earn more than
the usual market wages the co-operative
operates according to social and
ecological rules for which they're
German trade partners pay more and
that's the principle of fair trade
around one percent of German consumers
are willing to pay more for fairly
traded goods an insignia certifying fair
trade has been conferred for 21 years by
the Cologne based organization trans
fair many countries now have such fair
trade initiatives and in 2005 they
agreed to adopt a common logo Dita over
art started as a one-man operation in
1992 he turned a small coffee producing
cooperative into a hard-hitting team
nowadays the 58 year-old directly
employs 35 people he has tirelessly
campaigned for fair trade principles and
enlisted prominent supporters for the
cause
and it's caught on today even the big
discount supermarkets have begun to
offer fairly traded goods such as fair
footballs from Pakistan and fair flowers
from Kenya there's hardly a commodity or
product that can't be traded fairly on
world markets the Papa tile-based
trading company gaper was the first to
take on trans fair fair trade insignia
as a licensee begins and forcing
hundreds with you I'm we engage in long
term trading partnerships we pay for the
goods long before they arrive here to
give the producers money for investment
we create trading conditions that give
producers who would be disadvantaged on
a world market a chance to develop
thanks to transfer and it's committed
founder more and more people are buying
fairly traded goods and today he's our
guest on talking Germany detail over odd
yeah detail virat we agreed that you are
the kind of person who wants to change
the world around you to make it a more
just world and I want to understand
where that comes from in your biography
and to get there let's just go back to
your very early days to your childhood
now and have a look at one or two photos
there and just tell us about your
childhood let's see we've got those
photos there we go yeah is it we are not
we have not been small farmers but we
lived in Cologne yeah and we had my
father build a house and it was in a
community where poor families work
together so also neighbors concentrated
on building one house when it was ready
then they took they work together for
the next one that's very interesting in
this social orientation in the area
daily chance that we could live in a
house because my father was a postman ah
and he didn't earn enough to to to to to
build autobuyer Souls it was interesting
that these small village in Cologne yeah
is that each house was built by the
community as for
very interesting yes it was in the in
the late 50s yeah and we had a small
garden and nearly all the food we have
eaten from potatoes to apples we had
chicken etc so it was a bit living in
the countryside but on on the other hand
we lived in Cologne not in the scent or
not me as a cathedral but let's say part
of the city of Cologne so I i have got
good thinking about this time it was a
tough one my father was a postman yeah
we we didn't have a car or telephone or
television all these things came quite
late always always late but yeah I think
it has given me a lot of important
things and maybe not automatically
leading to a fair trade yeah but to be
grounded is one of the most important
things for my life that's fascinating
let's talk about fair trade because I
think one of the most important aspects
of the fair trade debate is to try and
discover how far fair trade has
penetrated into society into the markets
and I have a quote from you not too long
ago you said you hope one day that fair
trade might become mainstream that would
seem to imply that it is not mainstream
why is what why is that yeah I think we
are a bit talking about Germans and on
one hand we are all against artwork
child labor child labor yeah and on the
other hand we are let's say fascinated
to save money by during chopping and I
think the first discounter in the world
was founded in Germany and aldi and lidl
and all the other discounters are now
going all over the huge change that have
a mobile reach yeah and that has lead to
a situation say
we are used to it to buy cheap food on
the other hand we wanted the animals are
treated fair etc etc we do not want a
way of production but on the other hand
even with my parents I thought my mother
was glad when she went shopping and she
always was looking work and buy a cheap
coffee and even if she had to go I don't
know five or six kilometers she bought
three pounds of sheep coffee and she
feels happy and that is something i was
seeing it with you told your mother here
were actually seeing your mother here in
the family photo yeah that's a funny
it's a funny one and that is something
where I have seen that the way of
shopping of course at these days there
was no reflection at all mm about but my
my my first visit weren't conscious and
aware consumers in the first wouldn't
have been when I was active in amnesty
international yeah and when you go to
Central America and you see you learn a
lot about human rights relation you
automatically come this is a coffee
nation Salvador was called a coffee
republic or possesses is a naming of
being a banana republic in Costa Rica
etc yet to do with products with
commodities yeah let's talk about your
role in all this because one we were
looking at the reporter the the portrait
of you there there was some shots of you
as a relatively young activist and you
told me while we were watching it then
that you went to one of the big
discounters in Germany and there and you
were taken away by the police quite
literally since then what has happened
is that you are now working and
cooperating with that beer discounter
tell us about that process because they
are so important they didn't take us
seriously this hot Z the idea of fair
trade has to remain in the so-called
third world shops that's nothing for
main steam the consumers are not willing
to pay more for commodities that was a
they way of thinking and I think theater
is a special on theater they said on one
hand we are driven by civil society a
lot of NGOs are supporting and after the
first year when even a phone call just
took two minutes with a retailer and you
could see that this phone call comes to
an end and they said forget it mr.
overawed forget about this ID as a
German housewife will not pay any send
more clerk over and then with a lot of
groups church groups as we made in
initiatives that a lot of women walked
to the supermarkets and try to talk with
the owner always employees in a super
magnet we are buying here each day but
we want a fair trade coffee it was let's
say beginning and then this supermarket
gave a phone call to the regional
coordinator and said ok five women 10
women came and asked me for a bloody
fair trade product what's going on then
the regional coordinator gave a phone
call to the headquarter and they said
there's something going on the people
want something crazy in the same person
who respond to me saying forget about
this idea two months later gave me a
phone call and said ok we are putting a
fair trade coffee into the trails
tell me what the difference is between
the work that people do in one of these
third world stores would you get all
over Germany and have been in germany
songs antics workshops what's the
difference between what they do and what
you do yeah I think fair trade includes
a word trade and they are more politic
politically driven and they like to
discuss which is a good thing because
you can discuss a lot how fair is the
world business and but it's not the case
that our fair trade labeling initiative
is not political mmm that means but we
have to put some weight on on the table
yeah and for example in flowers when you
get more and more successful you are
changing is a production scheme in Kenya
for example in Kenya and Ethiopia the
environmental standards wages the non
Fairtrade farms get difficulties to get
good workers that means by this when you
get more relevant you can change things
even in bananas in UK where there is a
market share of around forty percent of
Fairtrade bananas then you can change
Chiquita you can change dole if you are
at a one percent level they say okay a
bit of fair trade doesn't affect our
business let's go on like we did it in
the past let me understand this in
concrete herbs because you just
mentioned wages for example one of the
promises of fair trade one of the things
that I understand is that if i buy fair
trade goods i'm going to do something
towards fair wages in the producer
country how do you how do you decide how
do you you know what our fair wage is
how is that worked out yeah we are
stakeholder driven that means setting
standards it's not one person and
overnight who says okay the minimum
price for coffee should be this we have
tough discussions between producers of
course they always want more and then
retailers traders importers and the
outcome of this discussion
at least there should the minimum price
would cover production costs okay I
think there's no discussion about and
then I got question is to what extent
the Fairtrade premium leads to in
investment in quality inn in education
etc how we should define is a theater
premium and of course if you say one
dollar more and the retailer says we
will not find any consumer who is
willing to pay let's say two euros more
for one pound of coffee yeah then it
will not work okay so I think it's a
balance between the interest of the
producers and this is in the focus of
fair trade but also a with what is
possible on the market how do you how do
you actually because of very important
to production and working conditions
yeah in all this equation how do you
actually monitor that yeah how do I know
that you are getting it right oui oui
it's called flossers that is the
worldwide certification company and it
is by far the biggest certification
company in in social certification in
the world they are separated from from
Fairtrade s NGO because we are convinced
that certification and control has to be
independent you're not influenced by
marketing people who say okay we need
this a chocolate producer even if they
are not fulfilling the theatre criterias
let them in no this is not possible we
have more than a 100 well-trained
inspectors and they are not going from
cologne or from one just one day to
Kenya looking a bit around and coming
back now they are based there see a good
trait and well paid because the oval
important problem is corruption yeah and
if they are not well paid then of course
there's a certain danger so I think that
we have a good network of inspectors
that in the whole supply chain the
producers export
the importer the trader and retailer
each quarter has to give us the figures
how much did they buy under fair trade
conditions what is surprising how much
did you sell to avoid that not that not
more fair trade products are sold here
is bought in the producing countries so
I think it's let's talk just about one
one one other aspect because there's a
relatively recent development is that
there are not just fair trade networks
there are also fair trade towns and
cities yeah tell me a little bit about
that yeah I I think we are not just a
brand on the package a logo on the
package it's in each country it's also
driven by civil society in for example
in Germany we have 37 relevant NGOs like
bread for the world miseria consumer
organizations etc and fair trade towns
is one expression that civil society
wants a better that the third world gets
a better deal and even the cities are
also consumer say buy coffee the
policeman has wears a uniform etc etc
and to start here that even the ZZ city
or the regional the region also has to
come to to to fair trade it's a tough
work
it's a very interesting report about a
very interesting project and I know that
it's very close to your heart yeah it's
because I'm I myself only past the eight
nine years on an ordinary high school
and then I start being a postman as my
father Wars or in a trineas officer and
I was glad said even with this low level
of education yeah I could do other
things and my my wife she's a teacher in
his cool axis and they even do not get a
real chance and that is something
because before fair trade I need to
explain because I think it's very
important that the viewers understand
the German education system is
effectively a three-tier system and you
were that you were at the low at the
lower tier of the system as the kids
essentially in this report ya and what
it means is that they don't get a fair
chance after that you will you have you
battled your way up the system yeah and
let's do that today I think the
conditions in the family are bit
different at this time they have been as
many immigrant families as we have
nowadays and my father and my mother
always cared about even it's a high
school that I do my school my my my
homework etc etc even at this level they
cared that a certain discipline is going
on and often this children and I've
worked 10 years with this employee to
young children before I started exactly
the Fairtrade campaign so it was the
most crucial point to get some structure
in their life and I I admire the main
work was to make networking with
companies in the region sets I get at
least a chance to work one month or two
months or three months in this company
and to see how working life goes and
this is something we have to find more
ways to give the children a chance and
therefore I think it's an excellent
initiative but for me the main thing is
to be grounded and not
to being a manager somewhere and just
talking with these big guys somewhere if
you are not ground that you even cannot
understand the consumers how's the
consumers behave and that is something
which still is very very very important
for me and still each afternoon or
evening here's a stories what's goes
still going on Itzik schools from your
wife or works more of these schools here
let me just ask you a more general
question we're talking about you trying
to have an impact in terms of justice
and fairness on an international on a
global level is is Germany as a country
is it a country that you associate with
social justice or with social injustice
it's really a fair country ah that's a
pretty good question even three weeks
before Election worm in comparison to
other countries I think it's a fair
country but still we have losers and
winners and tensors the tricky question
is if we during the last year's if we
got more losers and more winners and and
I think we can't sit like here and say
okay we have less days employees like in
Spain or in Greece everything goes well
if this is an attitude it would be a
problem and I think even is I had a
personal willing to improve my life we
need the same willingness at on a level
of society we have that life is
improving and that means with older
people etcetera etcetera so still there
are a lot of challenges and to sit here
and say we are a fair country no we are
let's say on a good way
it's a great project yeah finally grew
up yeah and I and I know edita that you
know a lot about the project because
you're involved tell us yeah one piece
was is the last one about fair deal fair
trade and I was involved in the creation
of the piece and I stayed together with
a group when the fs play in stuttgart
with a month go and even I'm now
involved in creating a new one and this
will take place by the end of november
in the Nationals heat of Nairobi oh yeah
before you tell me about the new play
tell me about the kids because I'm what
more impression did they make on you
what did they tell you about their lives
life has totally changed because being a
living in a slum or being dis employee
it totally differs from the situation
unemployed unemployed in inland in
Germany yeah so they really had a
terrible situation and arts with arts
you sometimes can found out at least on
your mood on your behavior it's not the
way that they earn money a lot of money
was with with theater it was just it's a
change of your mind map and that is
something where it's really powerful to
see but how the kids are changing and
even how they are influencing or giving
their attitude to other kids because we
know they are still even in a row we
where's the biggest slums all over the
world I think 1 million or one and a
half million it's huge and and this is
still they are located with with a
theater in the middle of office and
that's impressing how how it's a way out
of of their life your end and I still
want to support it and for me it's real
fun
the German director of the project he
was he was the artistic director he was
he was in your office yesterday he's
Austrian oh we gotta get that right yeah
yeah and he was in your office yesterday
yesterday and fair to Germany will
support as a disease a next or into
Germany and the first play will be at
the fair tight awards a big celebration
we will have in next March here in
Berlin and if possible I think five or
six times I also will play together with
a group and I try to be as nasty asst
will tell us about the role you're going
to be playing yeah yeah it's a factory
owner yeah and negotiation about celery
and things like that and I will be as
tough as a fair trade manager but in the
mm-hmm the contrary and I like this kind
of and your organization the
organization that you've built up in the
last two decades transfer yeah all the
principles that you've been talking
about about fair you know working
conditions and fair wages and what have
you to what extent do you apply them in
your own organization if you would ask
the easy employees if they feel well I
think you would get a good answers so
it's a question how is the atmosphere in
the company we play table kickers of
course they do not earn as much as in
the industry we got a lot of marketing
people coming from Mars coming from
retailers coming to fair trade and the
level of celery doesn't correspond to
the management salaries in in these
companies but i feel well we we have a
good mixture of young and all the people
and we have a mature or people who are
NGO driven who have lived and worked in
africa and marketing people who just
came from a totally different
this world and I'm proud that these
business people and online and in social
network young people that we form a team
working for one aim and we do a lot of
things together we are now 34 people
working and okay so that's your
organization you we've we've learnt
about how you work we've learned a
little bit about your background here's
the big question for me when I was when
I was a youngster like that you like the
little detail that we saw watering the
garden bear in there in that photo yeah
I could sense that the world around me
was a very unfair place that there were
people like us who had privileged lives
and there were people the vast majority
of the people in the world yeah who
really struggled who lived with poverty
and hardship yeah and I hoped in my
lifetime it would change yeah has it
changed or as has the world stayed the
same I fear it has stayed the same
what's your take no when in our
impression is and and our policies
producers it's a driver seat so feted is
not about charity sending some money to
somewhere in the place it's okay so I'm
not telling that UNICEF and all the
other initiatives are not doing good
things but the question is how you can
influence your life how can you be owner
of your life your working life and hear
my impression is especially in Kenya in
what we have seen in Africa people are
now more proud of course they are still
poor or most of them are still poor but
the way they are thinking about the ways
they are acting is more independent and
theatre it just can can give them a
framework to express their opinion and
the producers now have fifty percent of
vote of all the decisions we do is it
was not the case in in the beginning and
they are going to influence the region
the city so it's not just doing
something good in a coffee cooperative
doing something or to reach I'm going to
have to break you off there but a very
positive message and I think you won't
be over great stuff that is your lot
with data over ugh he's been a very very
good guess if you've enjoyed his company
as much as I have then come back to
talking Jay Lee next week otherwise you
can visit my blog on our website and
take care but I trust